welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse this is Phillip Molina and to meet
you this
yeah we're remitting you every time
because you have to be a new watcher and
welcome if you are this is a big
question folks this is a show where we
dive deep into the real nerdy questions
very mature serious adults grown-up
questions like space Hitler's sexual
history and that's this week's why
should I send you this I forgot it's
your fault and spoiler warning for the
rise of Skywalker by the way you've had
some time and if you're one of the great
viewers who watches the show with your
kids we love that you watch new rock
spurs videos with your kids that you
bring the family in but this might be an
episode that you might want to just play
in the background cuz we still get the
the view metric but Adam watch let the
boy watch sir you party watch learn this
is how I learned how these things work
as I watched the the late 90s version of
YouTube which was a bombs world or home
movies that I stole for my neighbor and
fuzzy pay-per-view yeah oh oh yeah geez
sexy we got some booze in the mugs and
who knows when I'll get when I'll kick
in it already has started but we'll
answer some other smaller questions
later Phillips got some gear that he did
some homework get out of here
okay okay I'm just so excited to see but
what is there a big question this week
Philip okay a lot of people saw Roger
Scott Walker and it was a film and in
this film we find out a certain thing
about a certain temper it turns out that
Palpatine he [ __ ] yeah he did
apparently I want to know everything I
want to know how he [ __ ] I want to
know when he [ __ ] I want to know why I
want to know who okay I want to know how
much a very artful way of asking who is
Ray's grandmother but the u.s. that is
not what I'm saying you did school up
but I want to know how she [ __ ] okay
all right I'll get to some of those
questioned out Palpatine had a son that
son is named only as Ray's father we
never even learned his name from the
credits of the rise of Skywalker he's
played by actor Billy Howell we also can
probably determine that Palpatine son is
not a clone
even the cloning does exist and in the
expanded universe and legend stories
Palpatine does clone himself this dude
is probably not a clone because one he
doesn't look anything like Ian McDiarmid
and you think they try to make him look
with Oh face behind me for the first
time the other reason we know that Papa
teen son is probably not a clone it's
because rises Skywalker kind of showed
us what Palpatine clones look like the
way he resurrects is partly by cloning
and that Palpatine is gooey and so is
this one this one so are a couple
Palpatine's we'll find out this episode
so I got my answer he do it gooey he did
it the old-fashioned way the gooey way
is how he had a kid so by using raised
age which we know and by estimating the
father actor's age we can kind of get a
window of when Palpatine probably
conceived when he smushed and by knowing
that historical period we can look
around at the people in Palpatine's
orbit to figure out who his partner
could have been because we don't think
it was a one-off like one-night-stand it
could have been but if it's gonna be
someone we can narrow it down to a
couple options so let's do the math by
galaxy there's a fertile yeah well if
you think if you're Palpatine you're not
just gonna [ __ ] anyone you're gonna
you're gonna see so when you can trust
it's got way darker than I thought it
even just Rey was born in the year
fifteen ABY and that makes her nineteen
when the force awakens occurs that
occurs in 34 ABY and just in case you're
not sure about this ABY and BBY are kind
of the Star Wars equivalents of BC and
AD right before the Battle of Yavin and
after the Battle of Yavin now actually
in the rise of Skywalker visual
dictionary they came up with a new way
to determine this setting the Year Zero
at the Starkiller base destruction of
the hosnian system which to be fair is a
much bigger historical event but we're
gonna stick with BBY ABY
that's the one that most Star Wars
lovers know and love so Rey's parents
left her on jakku when she was six years
old so that would be at 21 ABY and that
is also the year her parents died
because we learned a Verizon Skywalker
after they left jakku
that's when hochi caught up with them
and killed him and that's the same when
we see actor Billy Howell who is aged 29
years when he shot that that scene 29
years now so probably it would be 28
years whenever he shot that scene in
Star Wars years Ray's father would have
been born in the year 7 BBY but that's
if he was 29 so probably we're looking
around 6 BBY or might have been
conceived actually year earlier so we're
back to 7 BBY what was going on in the
year 7 BBY in Star Wars history well
this is about halfway through the
Emperor's take over with oldest 66 and
still strengthening his control over the
galaxy the Death Star is almost done
being built he's probably at the height
of his power but he was you know
disfigured I was gonna say he cute or no
no he's this this is this is after mace
windu melted of you he won't you know
from a certain point of view but he'd be
around 72 years old he was born in the
Year 84 BBY so at 72 years old that's
just around the time you want to start
having kids I guess I mean Larry King I
looked this up the oldest man to ever
father a child was named les Kali of
Australia he had his ninth child a son
at the age 92 oh poor woman oh my god
there was a third wife yeah a 92 year
old wiener well human males are able to
conceive children at that age obviously
but after the age of 30 male
testosterone drops one to two percent
each year some guys some of those just
keeps getting higher DNA integrity
declines it makes fertility less likely
yeah is like your DNA
hey but here's some good news look
forward to the testicles don't reduce in
size until after age 80
so it's 72 years old got some big ripe
plums on this guy
70 at 80 they start to get smaller yeah
and that does affect fertility exercise
your nuts they were like the same
some elderly inmates are getting their
nuts checked every gosh does this apply
to Papa Dean because he is a very
powerful force practitioner in normal
physics and biology doesn't apply to
that body you can imagine his swimmers
like Luke and the Death Star trench just
using the force to find their way to
that egg and blow it up the targeting
computer you but one thing I did find in
my research is that male fertility can
be affected by bodily harm in radiation
which that was deflected said lightning
that caused that
so yeah yes so they got they they might
have gotten fried like they look like
that to his nuts don't have an unlimited
power
they're super smooth those balls are
smooth as eggs now some people are
saying that Palpatine could use his
Darkseid abilities to conceive a child
via midi-chlorian magic or whatever so
you wouldn't have to have intercourse
the boring version of having a kid there
is that whole not firmly Canon back
story of how Anakin was conceived in
SHINee's would they have since said the
writers of that are saying that they
don't want people to think that means
that he created Anakin right I don't
know what else it could mean but yeah I
mean it was it was kind of in the comics
and there was like a draft of George
Lucas's script for Revenge of the Sith
were Palpatine tells him this so to me
that seems more Canon than not but he
didn't put his own DNA in Smith he
disease need and father a child he just
kind of like manipulated reality to have
this thing be immaculate so why would he
do it that way once and then a different
time later do it the old-fashioned way I
think that's what they're saying that
the whole Shmi story isn't canon and the
only time he has fathered a child was
the father of Rey now we have also
recently learned that force healing is
canon in the star wars universe so if
you did have a wreck tile dysfunction he
couldn't know you could just force heal
oh my god so that says everything your
dearly every time we masturbate on this
portal in our own tener they go from
flaccid to Iraq's airing and then life
finds a way I always like to be there
when the boy did break sooner so you
think he might be suffering from edie or
something
right at that age it's very hints calm
it's available for not as yet yeah
you're saying at that age he could be
suffering from Edie uh-huh and then you
just glanced over that I think you're
implying that he used SIF powers to undo
his Edie mhm I think we have to assume
maybe at age 72 he must've slayed some
puss you can say cuz Marina said it
first that's right she said it was fine
he has you know a mushy noodle it looks
like that yeah and you're saying he
needed to make it all dentist somehow he
was able to get to al dente and you're
saying oh because you're saying in a
galaxy far far away they don't have
viagra yes that's what I'm saying so but
they probably have something better than
viagra swill sit lightning force
healings so he uses force healing on
himself yes now another dimension of
this question is as a Sith would
Palpatine be allowed to because the Jedi
don't allow you to take romantic
partners to the Sith have the same rules
it's not clear there's some debate
online but unlike the Jedi the Sith are
not bound to the same dogmatic rules
they are they always go rogue that's
their whole identity but they probably
would not want to I mean Palpatine
manipulated Anakin to pursue love
because that made him more vulnerable to
control most Sith would probably not
want any attachment they're loners they
don't want friends on attachment it
doesn't mean you don't slay but they
can't be vulnerable right so you're
saying they but Darth Maul double dong
inch I mean even a momentary moment of
orgasm would be enough of a blackout to
have a city boner like I wake up a month
later in a hospital bed that's life
begins and ends in a hospital okay so
did Palpatine ever have a partner in the
legend stories or in Canon well in the
comics and the literary material puppet
II was a bit of a player he had a harem
he had concubine harem a Herriman has
been described one of the concubines was
named ro ganda is Marin she was a former
Jedi youngling who was kidnapped by the
empire and used her force powers to
infiltrate the imperial court and she
had a child with another imperial leader
to try to pass off the kid as
Palpatine's legitimate heir
it didn't work there was also another
woman in Palpatine's orbit named listen
is hard and she was the director of
Imperial Intelligence she's a badass she
tortured people in a prison underneath
course hunt and she briefly ruled the
Empire after the Emperor's death in the
Battle of Endor but neither of these
women are canon in the live-action
universe yet one woman is who was
innocent or 'but and i think is the most
likely option to be in love her and
raise grandmother sly more you may
remember her she's the bald female and
baron who's seen beside Palpatine in
attack of the clones she was like part
of his like guard you know she's a
senior administrative aide she was one
of the few people who knew that
Palpatine had a dual identity as Darth
Sidious she knew about all this and she
was force sensitive she used her
mind-control powers to blackmail her
successor to get into his inner circle
and in the literary material there were
actually tabloid rumors that sly and
Palpatine were having an affair and she
disappeared and it was believed that she
gave birth to a son who is the legends
character named Triclops
[Laughter]
really nineties Jedi Prince books this
is just what there's a lot of goofy
story to eyes but he just had one
monocle so they could American clubs
named by bullies clubs is not canon but
slime or has been in the movies the
characters there we don't know what
happened to her her force sensitivity
sensitivity plus her knowledge of
Palpatine Sith identity plus the
timeline this period to me makes her the
most likely candidate to be raised
grandmother but that's among characters
that we know about the other likelihood
is that there's just some other woman
that he met and he had this baby with
and we may never know her name or
Lucasfilm may just like say this was her
name this is what happened let's move on
this is a story of it it's also just
possible that he fathered dozens
of kids all over the galaxy like ego the
Living Planet you know he hooked up with
every life-form he could and that could
be something you could imagine Palpatine
wanting that or he could imagine him
being afraid to trust just strangers and
only wanting to father a child with
someone who is very close to him like
slime or some high bright we talked
about this before and I had brought up
Kiera from solo that was a nearly
Clarke's character she did have
connections to Maul in the dark side
many of speculate she could have been
raised mother remember not a grandmother
she was born in the year 31 BBY that
would have made her 24 at the time type
24 and 72 that is three times older your
age once again Larry Kane and this is
this is not a tight 72 like old cap was
this is a very loose 72 look if you had
to ask me if it was someone that we know
currently from the Star Wars universe
slime or seems like the most likely
candidate he could have taken as a lover
or someone some stranger that we may
never know so that's who he thought and
when he fought a seven BBY seven BBY huh
and how he fought for Seeley I hate this
I'm so happy that we answered this
question philip has an interesting
question he's gonna answer for us after
a short message from our sponsors hey
guys are you tired of big wireless
taking advantage of you
those companies can be like Sith Lords
running Hydra from inside Lex Corp or
something got I got my wires crossed
anyway I hate fees and bills that are
high for no reason we all hate them but
I like really hate them like Indiana
Jones with snake level hate well mint
Mobile is a great solution and thank you
to MIT mobile for sponsoring this
episode
mint mobile can help you save more than
a thousand dollars a year on your
wireless bill there's a better way to
get Wireless and it's mint mobile it can
be almost 10 times cheaper than big
wireless but don't worry for that
cheaper price you don't have to
sacrifice performance whether you're
making calls so from the internet or
checking social media to see how many
likes your aquaman fan art is getting
you won't be able to tell the difference
between MIT mobile performance and any
other carrier to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month
get it shipped to your door for free go
to MIT mobile.com slash big q again
that's MIT mobile comm slash big Q for a
new wireless plant for just fifteen
bucks a month
oh so 2020 is the perfect time to start
thinking about 2040 with Robin Hood you
can invest in the markets and earn
interest with a competitive API on
uninvested cash they make it easy to get
started and learn as you grow with an
intuitive app experience and no
Commission fees on trades and stock
prices don't have to hold you back you
can buy a piece of a company you love
for as low as one dollar and build your
portfolio a little at a time by one
share by half a share three and a
quarter shares it's up to you your
budget and your goals your first stock
is on the house when you set up your
account just go to big question Robin
Hood calm to learn more and claim your
free stock annual percentage yield APY
on uninvested cash is paid by program
banks and it's variable Robin Hood
financials not a bank the free stock
offer is subject to terms and conditions
all investments involve risk other fees
may apply just visit our B in HD CEO
slash speeds and we are back and now
we're gonna move on I can't believe you
guys came back I cannot believe you stay
with you we're gonna some bite-sized
questions but Billups got one big bite
so Phillip this question was submitted
by at baby once a Jeep how do you how do
Wolverine baby needs a Jeep
how do Wolverines claws work when his
wrists are bent so imagine that just
bent wrist that risk but the claws go up
into your wrist so in your own you get
out of my question okay at first it's
kind of like why is this a problem he
like he can bend his wrist right right
no this is so much more complicated I
created a very accurate representation
you created yeah all by yourself I stay
up all night doing this Alexi helped
okay he helped Wolverine he goes like
like you come come they retract ya come
at me Museum metal because I magneto
coming at you yeah and he's like ah
you got real close yeah try it again I
gotta go on to you what happened of
afraid to so that's like Wolverine story
now you guys know what will Prince like
here's the issue does he have to be
careful about his risk yes he actually
always has to when they draw him into
comics he has to come be coming at
someone with his wrist perfectly
straight in his hand straight so flash
witless you can't do one of these it has
to go straight you can't becoming like
with with a punch or a hook and it gets
really complicated actually as to how it
works alright so the reason is if his
claws are stored in his forearm which it
is in various forms of like x-rays that
they release and also movies and stuff
yeah they they can show it actually
there's different versions where it
sometimes is on top of his other bones
sometimes it's between them his own ends
radius and then it pushes through the
meta carsales and we really moves the
bones out of the way so it can shoot out
of roughly where the knuckles are so
here's the issue he started to extend
his claws but his wrist is bent then the
claws can't bend to so they would shoot
out of the wrong part so if I were to
bend this see now where these claws are
theoretically coming out of is out of my
wrist yeah up here yeah instead of out
of where my knuckles are or if I went
this way I can't do it because I'll
actually have to pierce my own hand yeah
come throw your home and they actually
showed this there's a time there's two
times very interesting one
Wolverine got really drunk once out of
nowhere has he had like basically space
liquor and it actually affected him
which it almost never does cuz of his
healing powers and so he gets so drunk
that he forgets to straighten his hand
and it shoots out of his palm all three
claws and he's like whoops and he looks
like realistic but another time in the
age of apocalypse story you can catch up
[Laughter]
he gets his gets his hand well I think
it's like melted off by Cyclops not
Triclops the and he has no hand and so
he's fighting and people are like oh so
he doesn't have claws no you stupid
idiot i stuff the claws in the form and
he shoots the claws out of just the
stump oh but it works pretty cool yeah
it's very cool here's what's so
confusing about like the physics of all
this okay
if he were to bend his wrist later also
a problem
I'm pushing the claws all the way
through uh-huh right that's like as far
out as they go so now they've left his
forearm and they're theoretically just
in his hands now now come at me okay
don't stop me you have short pencils
when I use these noodles al dente is
fine trust me I trust you uh you don't
get injured me you don't I don't want to
break it but well yeah I don't have
another sharpener so if it goes up and
he goes ah and he all the claws all the
way out to the knuckles they would snap
off when he goes to actually try to
pierce my hurry because there's there's
no the leverage is all the way on the
outside
and they're barely hanging on by these
little baby nuts here okay yes so then
this means okay his claws must be a lot
longer than right they still have a
significant portion of the club when
it's out what are you trying to do
you'll see okay so there are a lot
longer claws you say Eric Eric take her
away
No
so you're like oh the claws are a lot
longer and covered in saliva so then
this is how they stay in right that does
make sense for when you push them out
first like like now come at me come on
donate okay so if it goes I get it in my
forearm is much large the amount of
claws that go back here is a lot longer
it can push out and it's still strong so
if I if you if you came at me it
wouldn't break I have all this power but
the problem is when I reverse extend
retract and go back it literally in your
elbow yeah so he would have to walk
around like you do sometimes comfortable
or like the woman who never moves her
arms in Seinfeld yeah exactly so he
wouldn't be able to bend his arms for
that to work so immediately this
character is like so deeply flawed his
claws cannot work I have an answer as to
how his claws actually have to work it's
like the only way that this makes sense
one is yes they do have to be a little
longer than what he sticks out there
okay okay it's not fully extended there
is still amounts left up into his former
home but it's a very precise amount
that's actually the length of his
forearm because his claws are part of
his mutant abilities and not what was
given to him what they had mentally they
were bone claws they're bone claws then
they would naturally just kind of be
almost a replicant of his own arse
radius so they're just the right length
where they're exactly the length of his
forearm and then they extend a few
inches out but any artists that over
extends them and shows which they do all
the time they show these like multi
footlong katanas they're compensating
for something
mm-hmm Liefeld designs yeah exactly
because he doesn't even need them to be
that it's unrealistic their swords at
that point he basically just wants them
to be about finger length knives or or
even like maybe six inches out like four
inches still inside which is roughly the
you know a 10 size 10 shoe means you
have a 10 inch forearm do you know that
your foot is the size of your forearm
hold on
look now people know I'm wearing shorts
you've been trying to hide that for
years how about to rip something so
doing he's got clothes that are exactly
the size of his forearm a significant
portion of it still stays inside his
form it does not stick out that far
everyone else is just exaggerating this
is a really key part look at his costume
design look at the gloves and look at
the little metal shades that they
included little righties oh the scenes
that go right over each blade they're
actually directly to address the come at
me problem with his snap off they hold
him in place but and here's my
proposition
he must internally have his own bone
version of those shades in there that's
also anchoring them so that the leverage
problem doesn't happen where they just
fall out Wolverine got bone seeds yes
and if you look in a very classic design
x-ray design it looks like they kind of
attempted to squeeze that in really
quick they put these little circles
there and they didn't really like
acknowledge them but that has to be it
so he has little bone holes in there
that hold the claws in place and then
partially it's up there and it's exactly
the length of his forearm it's the only
thing that makes I love it now what if
they retract like lightsaber toys where
they they fold bolt and then fold yeah
could I do that like a human penis so
really you only need this much space and
in here that it could work yeah so they
don't and now they know I know where
start open just try to get you to show
your legs how's your bite size in the
last episode of hey we have time for one
the fan mail question right send them
your fan mail at the post office box
address listed below this one is
sentient by snacky Zack who asked what
are your new year's resolutions and have
you broken them yet oh man mine was to
drink less well my new year's resolution
was to learn how to shuffle a deck of
cards have I given up yet no I have not
I but I've gotten close I can
if only I had I should have thought to
bring my deck of cards because I'm like
a magician now I bring a deck of cards
with me everywhere I go God everything
like the one thing you weren't
20:21 will be to be a magician remember
there was a time in college when we
talked about like how could girls like
us better and one idea was we could
learn magic yeah that was from that neil
strauss book yeah and it worked for him
and well this has been a great episode
of the big question thank you to
everyone who submitted questions
continue to tweet us at new rock stars
using the hashtag the big question for
all your nerdy questions that you want
answered in horrifyingly accurate
scientific terms be sure to find our
audio version at the big question
wherever you get your podcast so you can
listen off your versions of this while
you're driving or working out or
whatever your new year's resolution is
and you can follow us on twitter at a
bus at philip molina anything else we
should add follow new rock stars follow
new rock stars and social media at new
rock stars and then just a serious
apology for anyone that hit that watched
that's it Happy New Year late January
[Music]